Exodus gods and Kings is directed by
Ridley Scott and stars Christian Bale as
Moses and joel edgerton as Rameses and
as you may have expected it is about the
events that occur in the Bible book of
Exodus Moses and Rameses their
opposition towards each other their
relationship and of course the parting
of the Red Sea and all the stuff that
comes with that as a filmmaker I have
tremendous respect for Ridley Scott not
only has he made some of the best
science fiction movies ever made but he
continues to this day to make a ton of
movies even if all of them aren't great
he is pumping out films faster than most
directors who are in their 20s and he's
older his careers a bit of a mixed bag
you can't always quite know what to
expect and with Exodus gods and Kings I
had the exact same remarks for the movie
it's a bit of a mixed bag for one the
opening battle sequence in this movie is
spectacular it is beautifully filmed
Ridley Scott pulled no punches when it
came to that and I would say everything
from the beginning of the ten plagues to
the end of the red sea sequence is
absolutely fantastic there's just a lot
in between that it's a little hard to
get through there's a lot of controversy
surrounding this movie because a lot of
cast they're just white guys and they're
playing Egyptians and you're like really
come on I mean Joel Edgerton is Ramses
I'm not gonna get too into that though
because I'm critiquing the film you know
the final product that being said I
think joel edgerton is a great actor I
like him a lot I mean come on the guy
has now faced off against Batman and
Bane if you're not convinced of joel
edgerton talents just check out warrior
he was absolutely brilliant in the movie
and I think he's a good actor I just
don't think he's the right actor to play
Ramsay's certain actors just stand out
like John Turturro as a pharaoh it
honestly felt like a spoof movie the
scenes he was in I was try not to laugh
it's like John Turturro is a great actor
but in Pharoah makeup it's just sitting
there giving orders to Christian Bale it
was like a comedy it's cool to see
Sigourney Weaver back in a Ridley Scott
film but she has like two lines so yeah
it's not much there but there were some
really good performances in this movie
namely Ben Kingsley and Christian Bale I
thought Christian Bale was great as
Moses he really knocked the park in this
movie had a lot of emotion to his
character it really felt his plight you
wonder
stood his strange position in life once
he realizes about his youth and the
final scene at the Red Sea was so well
done Ridley Scott really knows epic and
he clearly still understands how to show
an awesome battle scene but there's a
very long sequence in between there
where Moses is exiled he meets a woman
he starts a family and this entire
sequence dragged quite a bit because the
conflict set up at the beginning of the
movie between Ramses and Moses is
non-existent because they're separated
from each other so clearly the movie is
at its best and most fascinating when
these two guys are butting heads the
stuff that happens in between that is a
bit of a drag and there's some strange
choices in regards to portraying God and
I don't know I didn't really buy into
that aspect of the movie so there are
some really good performances in this
movie there are moments when the movie
is epic and awesome the entire film
looks beautiful Ridley Scott has not
lost his touch as a visual filmmaker the
problem with this movie is the pacing
and too much just happening it's two and
a half hours long it should have been
two hours I feel like it's entirely
possible that Ridley Scott will release
a much better director's cut of this
film in the future it's not like he
hasn't done that before I'm gonna give
Exodus gods and kings of B - I do think
that it is a film worth seeing for
specific moments but I also think that
it's a film that's going to be a little
hard to sit through for long drawn-out
moments so guys if you did see Exodus
gods and Kings let me know what you
thought of it below and as always thank
you so much for watching guys and if you
did like this you can click right here
and get stuck Munoz
Oh